ariana grande just unveiled the bloopers
and deleted scenes from her thank you
next music video and it is everything
we've ever wanted and more
isn't it true this song really is the
gift that just keeps on giving just
check out this Legally Blonde inspired
scene featuring Ari and Jennifer
Coolidge that was cut from the final
video I'm Ariana Grande and I'm her
attorney
Irie on a what yeah that's right big
this is my client and we'd like to
discuss an equitable division of the
assets well you two were together for
like a hot minute right so I believe due
to habeas corpus oh come again
you should be allowed to keep this
beautiful estate and she should get the
dog you came here for the dog the
[ __ ] dog oh I love it so much
I love a good f-bomb and I also love
that she goes yea big
ok hell you're really into this I love
it I love it so much
of course the epic moment was inspired
from this scene in Reese Witherspoon's
2001 flick but they got every single
detail down there oh they really are
from the Porsche convertible to the
outfits to the hair to the trailer they
even brought back the same actor to
reprise the role of Paulette's hubby
well they are not playing guys look at
this
I'm taking the dog thank you
[Music]
next but that wasn't the only thing left
on the cutting-room floor there was this
gym with Colleen ballinger who plays a
pregnant teen in the music video I just
oh my god me too so had a big lunch and
of course there was this hilarious
moment I heard Ariana's ponytail is made
out of an actual ponytail and the woman
that stole the show in the original
thank you next Kris Jenner of course had
these outtakes and if you thought you
loved her cameo before check out her
bloopers guys are so good I love Kris
Jenner me too
doesn't she look great in Rhonda Fung
way right honey when I was raising
Ariana I always told her that if a guy
ever [ __ ] with her she should just say
thank you next and if she ever had sex
without a condom she would get chlamydia
[Music]
so good she truly is a national treasure
I love you Kris Jenner be my mom yes
there's so many moments in this videos
oh my god so many and went ET sat down
with Hannah Lux Davis who directed the
thank you next video she revealed there
was one iconic scene from Mean Girls
that they didn't even have time to shoot
check this out
there was one scene I remember we we
wanted to do and when we got down to the
schedule and being like how much can we
fit into a shooting day and that's when
things started to get cut and it was the
backstage moment before the Santa dance
wedge happen but also like the lip gloss
like that with that Victoria's to get
lip gloss like oh my god and like it's
exciting like iconic moment I guess
remember as girls being like that lip
there's lips there was never enough and
her and I were very much like on the
same page at the lip gloss and even a my
breakdown like further in the first ad
if like what was in the scene I was like
was just no time in that shooting day it
is one of my favorite scenes you can
never have enough loot lost remember
lipgloss is a girl's best friend how the
song goes right exactly
course let us know which deleted scene
you love the most and be sure to
subscribe to all things et until next
time I'm at Halle underscore Stephen and
I met Courtney underscore tez oh no bye
for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]